We have three entries in the first vector, so we start by writing down three copies of the second vector and then we multiply each one of those copies
by the corresponding entry
in the first vector like this.
We bring the alphas inside like this, and here we're just
multiplying vectors by scalers
and finally we remove the
parentheses from the copies and we form a single column
vector like you see right here.
As an important aside notice that we have the following formulas for the tensor product of
standard basis vectors.
If we take the tensor
product of cat a and cat b, which we can write with
the tensor product symbol or without, as you see here,
then the result is simply cat ab.
If we want to write ab as an ordered pair rather than a string, we can do that and we obtain
this expression right here,
but it's a lot more common
to write this right here where we emit the parenthesis
but we leave the comma.
There is a sense in which
this one with the parenthesis is perhaps more correct, but it's a pretty standard
convention in mathematics
that parentheses are removed when they aren't necessary or helpful.
You can think about them as being implicit in this one right here and it's just less cluttered
and nicer to look at.
The tensor product has
an important property which is that it's bilinear and what that means is that it's linear
in each of the two arguments provided that the other one is fixed.
In a bit more detail it's
linear in the first argument which is expressed by these two equations that you see right here,
the first one says that
if we add two vectors, Phi1 and Phi2 and then take
the tensor product with Psi, we get the same result if
we took the tensor product
with Psi first and then we added.
The second one says that if
we multiply some vector Phi by some scaler alpha and then we take the
tensor product with Psi,
the result is the same as if we first took the tensor product of Phi and Psi and then we multiply the result by alpha.
And we also have linearity
in the second argument which is the same except that the roles of the two arguments are swapped.
This product of bilinear
is pretty straightforward to verify from the definition, but it's good to write it down like this because we'll often make
use of these formulas.
Notice by the way that scaler float freely through tensor products in the sense that's expressed by these
qualities that you see right here.
That is there's no difference
between multiplying the first argument by a
scaler alpha in this case multiplying the second
argument by that scaler
or multiplying the entire
thing by that scaler.
These equalities follow from
these two equations right here and because there's no
difference between these vectors, we can just write the
expression as you see right here
with no parentheses because
there's no need for them.
They're not adding any clarity
or removing any ambiguity, so we just remove them and
we get a cleaner expression.
All of this generalizes
to three or more systems.
We can define the tensor product
of of three or more vectors by generalizing the formula
for the tensor product of two vectors in the natural way,
which you can see expressed right here. Each entry of the tensor product is given by the product of
the corresponding entries
of the vectors that we're
taking the tensor product of.
An equivalent way to
define the tensor product of three or more vectors
is to do it recursively ultimately falling back on the definition
of the tensor product between two vectors. So if n is at least three, we can think about the
tensor product of n vectors
Phi1 through Phi n as being the tensor product between whatever vector we get by
taking the tensor product of the first n minus one of
them with the last vector,
and if you want to know
what the tensor product of the first n minus one vectors is, you either apply the formula
again in case n minus one
is at least three or use the definition
from before if n minus one is equal to two.
The two ways of thinking
about tensor products of three or more vectors are equivalent.
This time when we have
three or more vectors that we're taking the tensor product of, we don't use the term bilinear,
we instead use the term multiline,
but the idea is the same.
The tensor product is linear
in each of the positions provided that the vectors in
all of the other positions
are fixed. Moving on to measurements
of multiple systems in probabilistic states,
we immediately obtain a specification for how measurements
work for multiple systems by simply thinking about them
collectively as single systems
provided that all of the
systems are measured.
As a simple example, let's suppose that we have two
bits X and Y and collectively they're in this probabilistic
state right here,
which we saw before. Naturally, if we measure
both of these bits, we'll get the outcome 00
meaning a zero for the first measurement and a zero for the second measurement with probability one half and we'll get the outcome 1,1